as long as if I can't think of Tomb
Raider and not think of that song I
don't know if that was a goal of the
trailer but it did it so I hope that was
a goal Tomb Raider so Tomb Raider is the
newest video game adaptation from video
game to movie there were a couple of
other Tomb Raider movie starring
Angelina Jolie there were more in line
with the original intent of Tomb Raider
not polygon shakin titties are good it
was a point but they have since rebooted
the Tomb Raider games to take them a bit
more seriously it looks like this Tomb
Raider movies more in line with those
games in this movie Alisa vikander plays
Lara Croft her father disappeared about
seven years ago so she follows the
breadcrumbs as to what he was looking
for what he was searching for she didn't
know he was into archeology it looks
like his recording giving his half a
stupid-ass reason as to why he got into
it the first place I was enough for her
so off she goes gonna find some answers
but at least he vikander was great as
Lara Croft the set up alone I was like
okay we're not treating this like a
video game movie I like that she's down
on her luck but she still feels like she
has something to prove I find it
interesting when someone just has to
drive not a lot of skill but they have
some skill maybe some skill and fighting
definitely not in archaeology and then
they just fall into this thing I like
that then she lands on this island and
it starts to slow down yeah the pacing
takes a bit of a dip does pick back up
but I can't deny I was more interested
in Lara Croft before she hit that island
there were some pretty exciting action
sequences though that scene in the
trailer you saw with the rusted ice
plane that was really legit that was
straight-up some uncharted - stuff this
movie had some of those intense
sequences where something is following
she's inside as she has to grab on to a
Ledge it's following some or she has to
climb up and run before it falls I mean
those sequences aren't everywhere in the
movie they're just in a couple spots but
when they happen they're cool however
admittedly at a point in this movie it
makes a call a turn a plot point that
happens at I hate it it's like this plot
point is so unbelievable it can only be
found in a video game movie that's why I
really hated it it felt like everything
before that we were getting away from it
it was like Hollywood finally knew they
were like we know how to treat our video
game movies movie felt accessible until
this it crawls itself out of that pit at
times couple of things I wanted to see
in here.i day actually showed this girl
is not she's not killed people so when
she takes her first life it actually
kind of affects her don't linger on it
too much which is why it's worth a
dresser doesn't overshadow the movie
just this is a little thing that gives
character everyone else that they drop
like flies she's like keep it with a bow
and arrow man
you you you you had no problem after the
first one that's what they say right it
gets easier see I was alright some of it
was not it's like 50/50 I can flip a
coin as to whether or not I'd be like oh
yeah that looks pretty impressive and
the thing the term the point of the
movie the mythology that everyone's
chasing it's not that I didn't buy it is
that I didn't buy the fact that they
bought it one character in particular is
so convinced that this is real and you
don't know why he's convinced it's real
other than he's heard it's real but in
our world there are a lot of stories
about curse tombs and no one really buys
it and thinks it's real we all generally
speaking unanimously agree these yeah
it's probably stories this isn't a gripe
but rather an observation where they're
throw backs in this movie - Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade and also the
rock not the person the movie sure I saw
a couple nods but all art inspires or is
inspired by some other art is in the end
Tomb Raider was a step in the right
direction for video game movies it's
certainly not as bad as that abomination
Assassin's Creed in fact this movie has
a lot of enjoyment in it it's a movie
that's films like it's taking itself
seriously it's cast like is taking
itself seriously and really for a lot of
it is shot like who's taking yourself
seriously some of the issues in this
movie among pacing character plot I'd be
a bit too much for something I cannot
shake the feeling that this movie you
might be able to forgive some of its
flaws if you're a bit drunk yeah now
it's a party alright so Tomb Raider have
you seen it or have you played the games
what did you think about the movie
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]